you had an 18 year old brother who was
thinking about getting into the industry
and wanted sort of a big brother talk
what would you say to him treat it treat
it like a job you know as far as I'm
going to try to rephrase that treat it I
treat it like the hours of a job spend
that many hours a day trying to improve
yourself as an actor and focus more on
classes then on social media for focus
more and actually trying to try to be
good at what you do and I think that as
much as there is a lot of uncertainty to
acting and there is some luck involved i
think a lot has to be said for people
who just work their ass off I've seen a
lot of people who work their ass off
rise to the top and maybe you know not
even you know start and they didn't know
it like forever I hate when people say
oh you know you got to know somewhere to
start in the industry you know the thing
is you got it you got to work hard oh
there's pup you just came by hey puppy
uh you gotta you gotta work hard I think
that's the most important thing and and
our viewers may not know this but it's
like what two in the morning right now
yeah yeah it's two in the morning ah I
just had I stand another movie and had
two days home and then I started this so
it's been it's been an adventure me
that's why I'm open and I'm talking so
much maybe I'm just really tired
you